SMART TO WILLIAMS WITH THE PUT
DOWN. TICS.
TATUM 100%, HE
DEFINITELY SYRACUSE, THEN
PHILADELPHIA.
DID A TER ROLLS, AND EVERYTHING
DOWN ON THE BASELINE, BOSTON
6'9"220, REMEMBER THAT.
HE WAS A
AT AFTER BEING OUT FOR THE LAST
AND WE CHALLENGED THE BIG THREE.
WELL, THE BIG THREE HASD THAT'SE
HAS GOT IT, AND TO PLAY BOTH EN
THE FLOOR TO GET MORE MINUTES,
ESPECIALLY WITH ALL OF HIS
GO.
DEFLECTED, PASS TO CONNAUGHTON,
THEY'RECH
IS 8th IN THE HOME AGAINST
BOSTON, THE SECOND STRAIGHT YEAR
THAT THE BUCKS
IT'S 6 AGAIN, SMART SHORT ON THE
THREE, REBOUNDED BY A LONG PERI
TIME FOR SCORING POINTS.
>> Dave: 4-3, OFF THE
HEEL, LONG REBOUND CHANCE HERE.
OUT WIDE, HOLIDAY FELT HE HAD A
>> Hubie: GOTOT